today justice Brett Kavanaugh heard his
first oral arguments at the Supreme
Court and was welcomed warmly by his
colleagues it was a nice moment of
collegiality after weeks of chaos and
the promise of even more with only four
weeks till the midterm elections
Republicans are exerting more confidence
while Democrats are banking on more
chaos now despite the catastrophic loss
of the swing vote on the high court
they're hitting the anarchy accelerator
these people truly believe they can
protest their way back into power
something the president warned of
tonight the Democrats have become too
extreme and they've become frankly too
dangerous to govern
they've gone wacko but if Democrats take
control they will try to reverse our
amazing progress and plunge our country
into gridlock frankly into poverty
ultimately into chaos now the chaos
strain has now even infected what was
once the Democratic establishment like
why hasn't Dianne Feinstein who was once
considered a more sober minded liberal
why hasn't she condemned the tactics of
harassment and intimidation used against
her female colleagues in the halls of
the US Senate you know why because
pro-women Dianne Feinstein wants to keep
the atmosphere red-hot scarily so to
drive democratic voter turnout so just
when you think they couldn't go lower
they do Trump has delivered for these
people on the things that they care
about most he has delivered racism for
these people he has delivered misogyny
for these people and now he's delivered
the Supreme Court for these people which
is something that they've been trying to
get for a generation
they now have control over all three
branches of government we're gonna see
if this rain lasts for 30 days or two
years thousand-year Reich Reich nice so
if you're not on board with the moral
dictates of liberalism the left will
demonize you as a Nazi plant false
stories against you trash your family
try to destroy your life and though of
course they'll try to get you fired and
when you're President Trump or Justice
Cavan I love saying that if they can't
beat you they'll threaten to impeach you
here's the original founding member of
the Clinton war room
James Cargill the Democrats Cavanaugh is
worth a lot is worth a lot more alive
than dead
this is not gonna go away that they're
not going to stop doing stories on
Cavanaugh the Democrats were in the
house they'll probably hold some kind of
hearings on the fact that a lot of
people think that he perjured himself
during his confirmation hearings to the
Court of Appeals dead or alive
oh wait I liked him better by the way
when he put that garbage pail over his
head back in 2002 do you remember that
after the loss that was Carville's best
moment now how is any of this going to
make Americans lives better what is
what's the new platform vote for us and
we'll spend the next few years torturing
anyone who is even remotely associated
with Trump oh please now this thuggish
win at all cost approach was on full
display during the Cavanaugh battle the
numbers kind of why do women have to
bear their whole soul to you don't you
wave your hand
and it's fitting isn't it
that the woman who is one of the
architects of the politics of personal
destruction over with Carville has no
problem with any of that you cannot be
civil with a political party that wants
to destroy what you stand for what you
care about that's why I believe if we
are fortunate enough to win back the
house and/or the Senate
that's when civility can start again but
until then the only thing that the
Republicans seem to recognize and
respect is strength this is so juvenile
it's like your kid right well well well
I'll start behaving mommy once I get
that extra piece of candy okay so unless
the Democrats are in power there can be
no civility yet they are the agents of
mayhem that we've endured for two years
now this is what they've been doing
since election night Hillary would
rather see the country swallowed up by
discord and anger than to admit that
Trump's policies are actually bearing
fruit my friends this is all about
foisting a liberal construct on America
the tonality and the set of precepts
basically about open borders open
markets and maybe toss in gender
fluidity for good measure all of that
has to be accepted or else now what
happened to the softer kinder Hillary we
heard from just two years ago we need to
get better at finding ways to disagree
on matters of policy while agreeing on
questions of decency and civility how we
talk to each other treat each other
respect each other
I wasn't that nice at the Al Smith
dinner oh so nice unless our campaign
goes down in flames in other words and
unless our
opponent fulfills his promises in which
case we will scorch the earth civility
be damned Hillary could not even let the
moment pass for Brett Kavanaugh to have
a ceremonial swearing-in at the White
House last night what was done last
night in the White House was a political
rally it further undermined the image
and integrity of the court and that
troubles me greatly it saddens me
because our judicial system has been
viewed as one of the main pillars of our
constitutional government in what way
was this a political rally I was
actually there last night of course
people are excited just like when you
know you know one Democrat president
gets two justices or one justice you
know they're excited it's it's a victory
you can't celebrate victories it's only
for Democrats all of the Supreme Court
justices were sitting in the front row
if you saw any of that last night
including the one of course appointed by
your husband Hillary so it was a non
partisan moment of unity and maybe a
little bit of healing that Hillary
refuses to acknowledge because of course
she had no role in it now this is at the
heart of the Democrats and Tifa like
resistance they are actually resentful
that the country is moving ahead growing
thriving and reclaiming its power also
on the world stage because they have no
pardon at any of it
because Trump was right they were wrong
and they're ticked off about it
liberal Dogma and the give away policies
in the past that didn't get us here to
this this moment of achievement economic
achievement and otherwise lacking a
governing agenda or any response to
Trump's economic and global success well
the Democrats have decided to run on
just a platform of demonization they're
now even using the Cavanagh vote to
punish their own Democrats Senator Joe
Manchin of West Virginia in a close
reelection race and Tennessee Democrat
senatorial candidate Phil brezin are
being lashed by the left for their
respective votes and support of Kavanagh
the liberal moveon.org
and PAC Priorities USA announced that
they are withholding monies from the
campaign of both Democrats now if they
won't even tolerate a little bit of
diversity of opinion among their own
Democratic colleagues imagine what
they'll do to us if they regain power
and that's the angle